The Cloverfield movie-verse has now officially
expanded into some wild new territory.
Netflix surprised fans of the sci-fi film
series by dropping the third installment,
The Cloverfield Paradox, on Super Bowl Sunday
without warning.
Like the first two films, Cloverfield 3 offers
a new perspective on why all of those giant
monsters have appeared on Earth.
If you haven't seen it yet, you might want
to click away now because we're about to take
a deep dive into outer space.
Still with us?
Good.
The film centers on an international space
station crew who are tasked with trying to
solve the world's ongoing energy crisis by
testing a particle accelerator known as the
Shepard.
The mission is critical, as widespread starvation
and world wars threaten to break out on Earth.
The crew's miracle machine launch doesn't
quite go as planned, though, as it sends the
whole ship to another dimension.
So, how does the film tie everything together,
and what Easter eggs can be found floating
throughout the space module?
Let's take a look.
The obligatory Kelvin nod
As the biggest-named producer of all three
films, J.J. Abrams was free to sprinkle in
tons of in-references to his own life and
previous works.
Fans of Abrams may recognize the name of the
gas station that Ava Hamilton and her husband
Michael are waiting on line for at the beginning
of the movie.
It's called Kelvin, which is a brand that's
appeared in a ton of Abrams' prior projects.
It was the name of the man who occupied the
hatch in Lost; it was the name of a spaceship
in Star Trek; and even Star Wars: The Force
Awakens included a place called Kelvin Ridge.
The name is a nod to Abrams' grandfather Henry
Kelvin, who was very influential to his interest
in movies.
The Kelvin gas station logo previously appeared
in a scene from 10 Cloverfield Lane, so it
also makes sense to include it here for continuity's
sake.
And that's not the only bit of brand loyalty
Abrams snuck into the pic, either.
The Slusho connection
Another common thread found in most J.J. Abrams
projects is Slusho, a fictional brand of iced
drinks that seems to pop up everywhere in
Abrams' universe, from his hit small screen
series Alias and Fringe to Star Trek.
It also appears in the first Cloverfield film:
Jason Hawkins sports a shirt with the logo
as an homage to his brother Rob's new gig
with the company.
But their hand in the havoc that levels the
planet might be heavier than fans anticipated.
According to the in-universe lore, the brand
is owned by a Japanese mining company called
Tagruato which is heavily featured in the
Cloverfield Alternate Reality Game, and is
said to have set up offshore oil rigs throughout
the world.
The company name is also listed on a letter
sent to Howard Stambler in 10 Cloverfield
Lane, which led some Easter egg hunters to
believe their drilling platforms might've
opened up some kind of conduit for the original
monsters to emerge through.
Digital materials later revealed during the
run-up for 10 Cloverfield Lane offered details
of Stambler's job working with satellites
and the company's satellite launch — which
detail-oriented fans suspected had gone south
and opened up the floodgates of monsters.
However, the events of The Cloverfield Paradox
seem to challenge the long-held notion that
a satellite failure started this whole thing.
Alternatively, the presence of a Slusho bobble
head doll in the spaceship, along with a sighting
of the actual company logo on-board, suggests
that Tagruato has also been funding the Shepard
project.
So that means, yes, they're still totally
responsible for all of this, just not in the
way people thought.
In the last shot of Cloverfield - the original
movie - there appears to be a falling... something.
Perhaps that's the escape pod seen at the
end of The Cloverfield Paradox?
A brotherly bond?
Another common thread The Cloverfield Paradox
weaves with the previous sequel is the last
name of another prescient conspiracy theorist
showcased in the movie, Mark Stambler.
Yes, Stambler is the last name of John Goodman's
character in 10 Cloverfield Lane, and he,
too, seems to have some advanced knowledge
of the hellfire that would rain down on Earth.
Mark Stambler is seen giving a news interview
about his book, which shares a title with
this movie, and promoting his Twitter handle
"Paradox is Real" -- which is also real, albeit
inactive.
"This experiment could unleash chaos."
Some suspect the two characters might be related,
or even brothers, as it's certainly no coincidence
that they are equally impassioned about their
beliefs in this end-of-days event.
Howard Stambler's bunker guest-slash-prisoner
Emmett even makes fun of him in 10 Cloverfield
Lane by poking fun at his theory about "mutant
space worms."
That joke becomes all too real in Paradox
when our Russian comrade Volkov gets eaten
from the inside out after the ship's earthworms
are teleported into his body during the accidental
dimensional hop.
A familiar face
If the connection between the Stamblers wasn't
clear enough, there's an even closer connection
drawn between them by way of actress Suzanne
Cryer.
In The Cloverfield Paradox, she portrays the
broadcast journalist who's seen interviewing
Mark Stambler, and if she looks familiar,
there's a reason.
She also appears briefly in 10 Cloverfield
Lane as the injured woman who's desperately
trying to gain entry into Howard Stambler's
bunker.
"To clarify, you believe the effort to solve
the world's energy crisis might unleash demons?"
"She's begging me."
"Let me in."
"Do not let her in!"
Too bad she didn't listen to her special guest
that day, huh?
A mama monster?
In unearthed production notes for the first
film, J.J. Abrams, director Matt Reeves and
screenwriter Drew Goddard talked about the
theories and themes that went into the film,
and Abrams made an interesting comment about
the monster:
"He's a baby.
He's brand new.
He's confused, disoriented and irritable.
And he's been down there in the water for
thousands and thousands of years."
Given that Clover could level a skyscraper
without even flexing, it might've been hard
for fans to conceive of this creature as anything
even remotely resembling a baby, but the final
shot of The Cloverfield Paradox makes that
very possible now.
Whereas Cloverfield's Manhattan-shredding
monster was as big as any building on the
island, the monster that's shown ripping through
the clouds in the final scene looks to be
as big as some small countries.
Which means they've either opened another
dimension of craziness with that second Shepard
overload...or Clover's mother has come out
to play now, too.
Foreshadowing part four?
Mark Stambler's words during his on-air interview
should've been more harrowing to everyone
who watched, especially those on the space
station.
However, they tuned him out and got right
to the job of doing exactly what he was warning
against because, in their minds, the mission
of solving the world's energy crisis was far
more pressing than reading his promoted book
to see if he was making any sense.
But one thing he did say that, in retrospect,
seems important is how wide-reaching the interdimensional
warps of the Shepard would be.
He told the reporter:
"...they risk ripping open the membrane of
space time.
Smashing together multiple dimensions, shattering
reality."
"In the past, in the future, in other dimensions."
That certainly gives the Cloverfield movie
universe unlimited room to grow, and movie
four, Overlord, is expected to center on a
World War II-era encounter involving American
paratroopers and a Nazi-occupied village.
Stambler's suggestion that the past could
be affected by their space flub seems like
a clever way of keeping the film in the Cloverfield
universe, too, despite hopping back in time
a few decades.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!